it's been a devastating year in
California with wildfires burning across
the state they're blamed for the deaths
of at least eight people and the loss of
countless homes so far more than 4,000
fires have burned nearly eight hundred
eighteen thousand acres this summer's
Mendocino complex fire is responsible
for more than half of that destruction
the river and ranch fires combined make
up the biggest complex fire in the
history of California the flames are
leaving a trail of devastation but out
of the ashes the seed of an idea was
planted for a local artist Jamie wax is
here with his story Jamie good morning
good morning Elaine Darren's Sarkin is
making art to shine a light on the
ongoing crisis in California two things
he knows a lot about working in his Los
Angeles studio Darren's Arkin designs
lighting and installations for movie
studios musicians and corporate events I
try to take inspiration from what I find
in the world and usually that is more
meaningful than anything that I want to
create this latest project is personal
it began just over two years ago after a
wildfire tore through the Angeles
National Forest the sand fire as it was
called would torch more than 40,000
acres of land in less than two weeks
what's Arkin found driving through the
area was shocking and suddenly around me
the hillsides were covered in black ash
and tree nubs sticking out of the soil
so I got out and something encouraged me
to drag few pieces of wood back to my
car and then I just had them in my house
wondering what am I gonna do with this
the answer bring wood back to life he
meticulously carves grooves through the
wood which he then fills with strips of
LED lights
he adds shards of recycled glass and
applies polyurethane to preserve the
finished product when you're working
with these pieces what are you chasing
after what are you trying to make
I'm trying to find some beauty in the
ugliness trying to bring life to death
his pieces are now part of an
installation titled burning light which
is currently on display at the West
Hollywood gallery radiant space I had
gathered a couple small pieces of wood
before I came across this the charcoal
falls apart so easily yeah that I was
trying to delicately haul 100-pound log
back to my car and keep it from breaking
too much Sarkin has always been drawn to
the outdoors when he's not working he's
hiking and scaling mountains that
passion for nature has fueled the
burning light project the initial
inspiration for this came when I was
climbing in El Capitan in Yosemite in
2015 on the ground all around us
beautiful green lush nature but at about
a thousand feet up suddenly seeing
everything from above could just see how
dry and dying the forest looked this is
you trying to fix that in some small way
yes another influence for Sarkin is his
cousin a firefighter for the Ventura
County Fire Department currently there
are 8,000 firefighters on the frontlines
fighting six significant fires across
the state now here we are two and a half
years later in the midst of this
installation and California is again
ravaged by wildfires is that a visceral
experience for you right now sitting
inside of this installation absolutely
feel what inspires me most about this
kind of work is that it brings attention
to what's going on around us the the
timeliness of this is total accident
it's painful over the past five years
fires have engulfed nearly every corner
of California satellite photos capture
the plumes of smoke across the state and
according to NOAA
the smoke has reached all the way to the
East Coast
making burning
light a uniquely modern work of art it's
great when art meets a moment like this
right yes it's hard for me to say great
because what is happening is is awful
but great that people can have a more
clear understanding and hopefully we can
come together around that working with
his cousin Sarkin selected the wildfire
related charity kal fund to receive ten
percent from all the pieces sold in the
current installation so deeply personal
jamie i loved when you asked him what
are you chasing after and he said i'm
trying to find some beauty in the
ugliness trying to bring life to death
it's the truth you know there's
something about the the glow and the
space that's been put into these burnt
pieces of wood that seems to have
exposed the heart of the pieces the
heart of the wood it looks as though you
have to see it in person to really get
it definitely oh wow